il se relève les manches porte un casque
de hockey
david saint jacques est prêt pour une
autre bataille un combat contre la
pesanteur
ce n'est là qu'une partie de
l'entraînement tantôt il se retrouve
dans un univers virtuel
tantôt il est dans une maquette grandeur
nature de la station spatiale des parts
dans neuf mois avec un éventuel départ
dans quatre mois
si david saint-jacques devait remplacer
à pied levé le copilote de la prochaine
mission prévue en juin
des fois je me sens comme si je t'ai en
train de gravir une montagne avec la
rumba lancement au sommet de la montagne
fait que je suis pas encore prêt je peux
encore finir l'examen mais je me sens
pas mal confiant le débat en juin c'est
bon selon sa mission de six mois servira
à mener des expériences scientifiques
notamment sur ce difficile problème de
la pesanteur est ce qu'on serait capable
d'aller sur mars aujourd'hui c'est
risqué photo capable ça serait ce comme
si on se demandait et on vient
d'inventer leur radeau on est tous cas
pas à tracer atlantique mars à l'horizon
2030 c'est le nouvel objectif de la nasa
établi par le président trump la station
spatiale dans ce contexte trouve une
autre raison d'exister selon david saint
jacques
c'est comme s'ils ont testé l'imprimante
camping dans la cour avant d'affronter
le reste les vrais ses marques
l'everest notre prochaine est venu très
grasse en ce moment c'est mars mais la
survie de la station spatiale n'est pas
assurée donald trump a déjà déclaré
vouloir en arrêter le financement à
partir de 2025
pour david saint jacques la réalité est
plus proche s'affichera nef sur le papa
parce que c'est clair que c'est
objectivement très dangereux évidemment
voyage a refusé un retour à ces vitesses
là dans l'atmosphère mais le programme
spatial s'animant stride équipe 48 ans
ingénieur astrophysiciens médecin david
saint-jacques s'apprête à réaliser ce
grand rêve est ensuite retrouvé sa
conjointe
trois jeunes enfants pour une vie plus
normale ici maxence bilodeau
radio-canada houston